one of Holt's animators Mark Davis told
me this years ago he said if you work
for Walt Disney you were asked to bring
something to life and that's a tall
order you said afterwards and all of you
guys did that you brought something to
life in a fantastic way so thank you for
doing that but this evening I'm going to
present the awards in outstanding
achievements for both alternative and
animated film making and i'll start with
the category that's easily the most
misunderstood in the competition the
alternative category alternative films
often challenged the language of film
making personal expression and aesthetic
exploration their primary concerns in
fact then me sometimes even defy
explanation however while the Academy
voters needed no explanations they did
find themselves with enough questions
that they selected only two films was
here to represent this category and here
we go earning silver medal honors is a
film that comes to us from the School of
Visual Arts in New York the filmmaker
kaye-boom shown says that his film is
about our purpose in life and the many
factors that shape it these include
teachers mass media culture and
socio-economic systems and believe it or
not he's covered on in just nine minutes
so it's my pleasure to present the
silver medal award in alternative
filmmaking to quibble chung crevo good
evening well it's pretty nervous I
direct thanks to my family especially my
feelings who just come from Korea five
aliso go for this ceremony
thank you mom and dad and I love you and
I'll direct thanks to my sister and
brother-in-law win sook una wen zhong
wen yong yong joon and so on thank you
very much for your encouragement finally
our schedule thanks to god he has always
given me more the Creator I prayed thank
you God thank you
you